mobile devices not only have different
numbers of actual pixels but they fit
very different numbers of pixels into
each inch of screen real estate
so to get roughly consistent formatting
they pass different numbers of layout
pixels into the viewport
this chart shows the number of physical
pixels for each device their device
pixel ratio
and then the resulting layout viewport
if we look at the number of device
independent pixels per inch this results
in for each of these devices
we'll note that almost all the mobile
devices are very close to 160 device
independent pixels per inch
this makes layout design much easier for
us
the device pixel ratio gives you a clue
as to how high resolution the screen
really is not just how many layout
pixels there are
you can use device pixel ratio in media
queries to control properties like
background images and in fact this is
going to become very interesting in the
next lesson where we learn about how to
use adaptive images